[موسيقى]
ميسي يعود الى برشلونه وتوتنهام يحارب
العنصريه ضد الصنع وكابتن ماجد في الدوري
الكولومبي هذه الاخبار وغيرها نقدمها لكم
من العربيه رياضه اهلا بكم
بعد تعرض لاعبه لاهانه عنصريه وهي ليست
المره الاولى بالمناسبه طلب نادي توتنهام
الانجليزي الشركات المسؤوله عن مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي كتوتر وانستجرام باتخاذ
الاجراءات الرادعه بحق المعلقين بعد تعرض
المهاجم سون هيونغ لاساءه عنصريه خلال
مباراه توتنهام ضد ويستام بالدوري
الانجليزي وفي اغسطس الماضي كان نادي
تشيلسي قد عاقب احد ملاك التذاكر الموسميه
بالايقاف لاجل غير مسمى عقب توجيه اهانه
عنصريه للاعب الكوري الجنوبي
ودعا لاعب اياكس امستردام الهولندي ومنتخب
غانا محمد قدوس صديقه الراحل في زلزال
تركيا كريستيان اتسو برساله مكتوبه على
قميص تقول ارقد بسلام يا ادسو وذلك عقب
تسجيله هدفا في شباك سبارتا روتردام
بالدور الهولندي ولم يحصل قدوس على انذار
رغم خلع القميص حيث قال له الحكم ان خلع
القميص غير مسموح به لكنني اتفاهم الموقف
ليرد قدوس انا ممتن للحكم واقدر ما فعله
في الوقت الذي كان يتصدر فيه ميسي وسائل
التواصل عقب احرازه هدفا قاتلا وساحرا في
مرمى للفرنسي قاد على ابره فريقه للفوز
باللقاء رصدت عدسات الكاميرات الاسبانيه
لقطات للسفر النجم الارجنتيني من باريس
الى برشلونه صحيفه موندو ديبورتيفو
الاسبانيه ذكرت بانها المره الاولى التي
يعود فيها ميسي الى كتالونيا بعد حظه لقب
كاس العالم الجماهير العاشقه لليورا بطت
بدورها الزياره بالانباء المتداوله حول
حول امكانيه عودته للعب في نادي السابق
بعد انتهاء عقده الحالي مع باريس سان
جيرمان الفرنسي
زين نادي ديبورتيفو بيريرا الكولومبي
مدرجاته بالامس خلال اللقاء الكلاسيكو ضد
اوسكار
يحمل صوره الكابتن سوباسا او كابتن ماجد
ورفاق وليد وياسين وبسام وانتهى اللقاء
لصالح اصحاب التيفو الجميل بثلاثه اهداف
مقابل هدف